and i went and got in the end when i
went and got my big cyrix panel it was
like 19 vials that day
and um i was like what's taking so long
and they're like you have a lot of
different
ordered tests here and we're just making
stickers like it's all the stickers that
put on the tube so yeah it's it's nine
was not much look at all the tubes to
make sure that your name is actually on
that i know
quite the process but i guess it gives
you the peace of mind that your results
aren't going to be mixed up with you
know your 90 year old neighbor down the
street so
yeah so
nine vials and you know showed thyroid
was low so of course i think here's the
magic pill um some of the other things
that had been symptoms were like i
definitely noticed like dry skin dry
scalp like less a little bit of thinning
hair
a little bit of weight gain all the all
those kinds of things and i thought man
this is it
oh my god if i only knew there was going
to be so many more blood draws after
that
and so you have to wait a month to get
your next thyroid results because it
takes that long to kind of you know let
the body adapt and so in the process of
that um i
get turned on to your book boundless and
i'm flipping through it i'm like man i
would i just would really love to talk
to you and so we set up that interview
and i said what would i want it what
would i need to do if i wanted to know
like all about food what to eat when to
eat it how to work out when to like what
if i could like dial myself in what
would i need to do and you gave me a
list of tests that were everything from
the longevity test of 19 vials to the
neutral valve which i think was the
toxins like nutrients and toxins tests
the dutch test for hormones the strategy
for um pathways i think that's kind of
what it tests right like there's
different gene tests
genetic pathways some some so-called
dirty genes that tend to be the actual
problematic ones that you want to pay
attention to versus like the the big
laundry list of genetic data you might
get from you know like like a whole
genome analysis but you know 90 of that
is just like
it's it's down in the weed stuff that
you don't need to pay that much
attention to
so i like that that dirty genes test
that's uh dr ben lynch's test called
strategy because you just get like the
super actionable information you know
like the nine or ten dirty genes that
you actually need to pay attention to so
so yeah was 10 it was a 130 page test
well it's it's
so it you can take as deep a dive as you
want to into the results but really like
the first
four or five pages of the report that
you get from strategy is what you
actually want and the other ones which
is the most humbling test ever ever ever
ever and i've done it twice now is the
stool test i just want to like frame
this for people because they think it's
uh funny and um it's a great thing to do
by all means but you basically have to
poop into your hand you get a glove and
then you get like these hot dog trays
you know like if you were going to the
stadium and it's a hot dog or french
fries you know you poop into that every
day for three days and then you have to
scoop out of it it's the most humbling
experience
ever ever ever ever ever and i've done
it twice now um not only that but it's
you're you kind of feel like you're
pooping under pressure like pooping
performance
like a little bit of inevitable like
constipation that occurs as you're just
trying to figure out how to aim just so
so you get it in the hot dog tray and
you put your special gloves on that they
send you to clean up the mess and then
and then afterwards you got to put it in
the fedex container put that in the
refrigerator and explain to the family
that that's your poop in the
refrigerator waiting for the fedex to
come pick it up and then worse yeah
right next to dinner right exactly and
because kind of like the golden standard
way to test your gut and this is i think
what a lot of practitioners miss
is
it's gross to think about but like
parasites for example they're gonna
they're gonna shed over the day and over
multiple days and so
if you're just testing on one day you
might have a critter in your gut for
example or you know some type of
bacterial marker that doesn't show up on
one test but by doing the test over
three days and and submitting three
samples you get more accurate data yet
it also means that you got to repeat
this damn thing like three days in a row
so yeah it's it's yeah good actionable
information but i agree
humbling humbling but anyway so i did
all those tests and um i got them all
organized and it is an organizational
process there's certain things you can't
take while you're doing it there's
certain things like staying away from
fish for some or staying away from
probiotics for another or you know
a certain biotin biotin can mess up
certain tests so there's a bunch of
stuff that you have to really read them
and so i felt like i was a
second grader reading them i'm like oh
there's a lot of information but got
that going and then in the meantime my
doctor had recommended i i see a
functional doctor i called her up and um
you know luckily got in because these
doctors can be hard to get into and she
was glad that i had started all those
tests that you recommended um and then
she started recommending some more once
those tests came in so like an
additional one that i ended up getting
especially after seeing the toxin report
was um i got a heavy metals test so i
did the provoked heavy metals test which
ended up kind of seeming like maybe a
key to the whole thing because my
mercury was just like astronomically
high you had the the mercury results of
a true sushi lover and and you you
dropped a a term there that some people
might not be familiar with uh provoked
tests
a provocation test for metals typically
means that you are
consuming something like edta or dmps or
dmsa or what would be called a
provocation agent which allows the body
to be able to increase the urinary
excretion of certain metals or elements
and
sometimes a non-provoked test will not
necessarily detect with the greatest
accuracy what metals you're high in and
then when you do a provoked test it'll
really show you know rampant levels of
for example in your case mercury and so
that's why i'm actually a fan of of that
provoked test and you also did uh the
the neutroval analysis which i
absolutely love it's like kind of like
it looks like micronutrients that fatty
acids are the amino acids that a lot of
the little things that a basic blood
panel won't test for you know the
neutroval is it's like a combo blood and
urine test so you got like 125 different
biomarkers that that thing's going to
look at you know antioxidants and
vitamins and minerals it's it's a it's a
very um
it it's a very commonly used test in
functional medicine for people who are
kind of stepping back and looking at a
very holistic approach in terms of blood
and biomarkers
and it's it's um also one of those tests
that detects metals and you kind of had
like a double positive right in your
provocation test for metals you tested
hype for mercury and then your neutroval
test also showed you're high for mercury
so there's no doubt that there's some
some metal issues going on as well yeah
and it's my understanding uh
because i was diving into this as much
as i could to learn more about it
because it just seemed kind of really
surprisingly high
that the
non-provoked part of the test will give
you kind of more of a recent body burp
more of a recent read on your on your
levels and the provoked is a little bit
more of a total body burden is that
right
yeah yeah and the
the provoked test will increase renal
excretion of certain elements that you
that you wouldn't excrete in a
non-provoked test so
it it you know i'm a fan of of getting
what would be called a provoke test or
collated test just because you you can
see a little bit more you can compare it
to the non-provoked results uh and
kind of see what may have been happening
historically versus what's in your body
now but i think if you had to choose one
i'd get it i'd get a provoked test or a
neutral valve you know so also my doctor
also tracked my blood with
the mercury in my blood because and i
had said i thought from all my readings
that that wasn't the most accurate and
she said it's it's not the best but it
is definitely an ass it helps us track
it and so like my blood mercury level i
think when it was initially tested maybe
42 and then it went down to 31 and so
i'm not sure where it is now but i mean
the process has been going on so then i
learned a lot about um
detoxification and
sweating and poop pee sweat all that and
saunas and so so it's been quite quite
the journey but i would say the large
bulk of it after i got the results back
from the longevity test the cyrex test
with all the all the for all the foods
was that i had leaky gut like crazy like
everything is on the list i mean it is
it is is it's so much it's so bad there
was only like one herb i could have i
think it was parsley and i think that
there was two
maybe two different seasonings i think i
could have turmeric and paprika and and
that was about it and then like almost
no proteins the only proteins i could
have were something like scallops
cod
um
to help tilapia and halibut no those are
the only things that reacted low but
then of course once i got the mercury
information i was like [ __ ] i shouldn't
be eating fish
and um so anyway so it was basically
like gut healing first for three months
and a whole pill protocol
to
live up to and eliminating all as many
of these foods as i could and then after
the three months
i did this stupid thing where i ran a
marathon um so i ran the boston marathon
so during the gut re rehab i was also
training for a marathon why not engage
in a sport that is that is well known
for increasing gut permeability uh while
you're trying to heal a leaky gut
i said yes to that last year so you know
i like to live up to my words so um so
train for that and also doing the
punishing training in arizona which i
never realized how much heat played in
elements of but i mean 100 degrees in
the sunshine at eight o'clock in the
morning is is just dumb and um so anyway
so i did that and then finally after the
marathon was when she said we could
start with chelation which is you've
kind of said the word but it's basically
using one of those key laters that you
would use for the provoked urine test
dmsa is what i'm using and you just use
more of it and so i'm on a five day on
nine day off um cycle for three months
essentially so
um and with binders which are clay and
charcoal and all those things so that
the the metals have something to bind to
so i can eliminate them instead of
redistributing them
i've covered that with dr dan pompa on
my show the problem with just let's say
finding out your high-end metals and
um maybe taking boatloads of cilantro or
charcoal and not activating the liver
detox pathways which means you're
binding up some stuff but not that much
or vice versa taking a bunch of things
that would activate or
or
um or increase uh any of any of the
phases there's kind of like four phases
of detoxification in the liver but then
if you don't simultaneously use a
binding agent you get what you just
alluded to that redistribution and a lot
of times that redistribution occurs kind
of osmotically and the brain is the
section of the body that tends to be the
lowest in metals typically in someone
who is metal burdened and so you wind up
with what would be denoted as like mad
hatter syndrome you know it was the the
people who used to make hats way back in
the day apparently used metal that was
high in among other things mercury and
wound up with all these crazy symptoms
and so there's actually something too
being the mad hatter but the problem is
if you're doing a detox protocol it's
not well formulated you're just kind of
doing a diy type of thing and increasing
liver detox pathways without a binding
agent you can get metals redistributed
into neural tissue which then winds up
creating a whole host of other like
mental and emotional issues so yeah you
have to if you test high in metals do a
well comprised detoxification protocol
either overseeing as you're doing with
the functional doctors using chelating
agents and then also the agents that
increase the liver detox pathways or the
other one that i tend to recommend
because i i think it it's one of the
better formulated detoxification
protocols out there is um dr chris shade
in in boulder he has his company
quicksilver scientific and they do
something called their detox cube
which is basically like glutathione uh r
lipoic acid vitamin c
uh some some kind of like an intestinal
cleanse formula that has some of those
binding agents in it and
it's like a three-month protocol but it
just kind of comes to your house in a
box and you just basically follow the
instructions and i i've used that with a
lot of people who have asked me about
what to do about their medals and done
pre and post analysis and it seems to
clear up metals like i mean just
perfectly so that's that's kind of like
it's not quite a diy solution because
typically for that particular cube you
need to
go through a practitioner to have it
ordered but like you know i you know
like like for quicksilver for example we
do we just have a code that we use and
and you know i get that for the clients
who want to do it who don't have a
functional medicine doc who they're
working with who kind of knows how to do
a metal detox so there's kind of two
ways to go about doing it but the way
you don't want to do it is to go to
whole foods and buy a bunch of cilantro
and activated charcoal and you know kind
of
kind of do your own thing yeah it can be
it's dangerous
for metals yeah and then you also talked
about how you were doing the sauna and
things like that and you know for for
metals and i realized we're kind of
rabbit hole and getting getting all over
the place here but i'll throw this in
and then maybe we can in a more
structured format go through go through
your labs
more systematically
but i i i'm a fan of for people who
don't want to arrive at let's say
january 1st realize their burden with a
bunch of metals and toxins do their big
yearly detox and then you know wait a
year and then do it again which can be
pretty stressful in the body i'm a fan
of life just including naturally worked
into your daily routine specific
protocols that either enhance lymph flow
or allow for
greater amounts of sweating through your
body's largest detoxification organ your
skin care for the liver etc so for
example uh once a week like every
wednesday i
do a
coffee enema right which which actually
does a fantastic job starting to
activate a lot of the detox pathways in
the liver amplifies bile production in
the gallbladder kind of cleans out the
colon a little bit so i always do a
coffee enema usually with some butyric
acid and some olive oil and some other
nourishing elements for the colonic
flora in that enema and then take
charcoal afterwards go in the sauna for
about 30 minutes sweat everything out
and typically in the morning prior to
doing the enema i'll do like 10-15
minutes of rebounding like up and down
on the trampoline which also helps with
those detox pathways and so every single
week
seven times a year i'm getting like a
weekly kind of like mini cleanse
dictating that you know when when the
end of the year arrives i don't have to
go out and do any kind of like special
fancy detox and and the other thing that
is helpful for this is the concept of
cellular autophagy and giving the gut a
break and allowing the body to
engage in its own cleanup protocols and
that's where i think some type of
fasting regimen comes in handy like you
know when you look at a lot of religions
they always have these these times of
the year when you might have a protein
restricted time or a time when when
you're calorically restricted or if you
look at a modern example like dr walter
longo has published lots of research on
his so-called fasting mimicking diet the
fmd diet where for five days you're just
eating 40 percent
ish of the number of calories you would
normally consume thus allowing your body
to engage in some amount of cellular
autophagy and you get a lot of benefits
from that fast without being super duper
calorically or nutritionally restricted
and then there's also kind of like an an
ayurvedic type of cleanse called the
panchakarma cleanse which involves
eating this special type of stew called
kitchery for uh five days in a row along
with some amount of olive oil or ghee
some grapefruit juice to upregulate the
cyp enzymes and liver
um you've probably no doubt heard about
you know juice fast and bone broth fast
etc but what i'm getting to is
what what my strategy is is on a
quarterly basis i'll choose a four to
five day time span and just do some
element of a of a cleanup that's a
little bit more intensive so like in the
spring i might do a kitchery cleanse
sometime in the summer i might do a
five-day bone broth diet starting off in
the fall a juice fast and then maybe at
some point in the winter doing something
like the fasting mimicking diet so four
times a year and a lot of times because
i'm in the nutrition industry i just
like to play around with the new fasts
or the new kind of cleanup protocols
that are out there so i just use as an
opportunity to do a little bit of
immersive journalism but i think
systematically weaving in on kind of
like i do on a weekly basis something
like you know rebounding a sauna an
enema and a binder and then on a
quarterly basis doing some type of a
some type of a fast like an intentional
caloric adjustment or dietary
composition adjustment is a really great
way to just kind of like woven into your
life systematically throughout the year
ensure that you're not getting a build
up of
all these metals and toxins and things
that inevitably
even if you're living a healthy life
you're kind of exposed to you know
everything from brake dust to the you
know plastics on the back of receipts to
you know the jet fuel you might be
breathing when you get in the airplane
like the fact is we just don't live on a
pristine himalayan mountaintop so even
if you're super healthy
and your home environment has dialed in
the fact that we live in an era where
there's just so many things we're
getting bombarded with dictates that
it's kind of a smart strategy to not
just like wait and wait wait until stuff
builds up uh kinda like kind of like
what happened to you and then doing this
massive detox that can be you know
expensive and hard on the body and and
you know very nutritionally restricted
versus just adjusting your life
so that your body's just constantly kind
of detoxing throughout the year if that
makes sense
great great great advice in which i will
be taking and i've learned a lot about a
lot of these things in the process
learning about what the hell is
autophagy learning about giving your
stomach a break and having certain
windows like i've practiced much more
like 12 hours of of you know from dinner
till breakfast time just to give my
stomach a break and learning about you
know eating every four hours for your
stuff just little tips and tricks not
snacking i mean again another all over
the place thing i used a continuous
blood glucose monitor this summer for a
couple of months while i was doing all
the while i was doing the gut protocol
like started it which was so educational
but anyway in the process i learned a
lot about a lot of different things that
i'll be implementing but some of those
are some really great tips to do um i
literally have written down my coffee
enema i had someone else tell me to do
one too and um
i don't want a video on how to do it i
just pie spice latte coffee enema it is
just
organic
free micro toxin-free
organic coffee and and like i mentioned
you you can you know it's so funny
because like historically enemas have
been a a common practice especially in a
lot of alternative medicine circles and
you know even in a lot of um you know
just like
cultures and indigenous tribes and and
um and people from all around the world
have used their butthole as a way to
either deliver medications or do
something like an enema and
um it's one of those things where it
seems like in america especially we're
very very
kind of uh
from
almost like a puritanical perspective
very wary about anything that goes near
the butthole but in reality like like
doing an enema is once you get used to
it it's kind of like brushing your teeth
it's it's not that difficult to pull off
and
if you're doing something like a coffee
animal like i mentioned you can put you
can like make yourself your your coffee
let it cool down of course that's
important and
like room temperature or lukewarm and
then like i mentioned i'll actually put
things in there to help to either soothe
the colon or
um or or feed the colonic flora or line
the intestinal wall or the clonic wall
so what i mean by that is i'll do the
coffee enema but then typically i'll put
some extra virgin olive oil in there for
the oleic acids and i'll put some
butyric acid like a couple of butyric
acid capsules in there because your
colon loves butyric acid a little bit of
probiotics like that berberine is
butyric acid berberine is that
no it's like what i use is one called
tributary which is which is a really
good stable form of butyric acid and it
just helps you poop like a champion and
then um what what you do is you you just
stir that stuff into the coffee right
and then you just lay down on on your
side on the bathroom floor and you get a
good book and and let it all go into
your into your colon lay there and read
for about 20 minutes get up take a take
a poop and you know then go do your
sauna or whatever you're going to do
afterwards how do you know when it's
done is there a certain amount like it's
12 ounces or it's 16 ounces or whatever
ounces then you just like let it flow in
there and lay there or how do you know
when it's done because i've had a
colonic a couple of times and it's like
you know with a professional it's like
it turned the water valve on it fills up
it feels you feel a lot of pressure and
then they release the valve and they
keep doing that over and over again
right
the yeah this is a lot different than
that protocol which which i've had done
but obviously
when you're making health decisions
about things you're going to do on a
regular basis it's ideal not to
necessarily have to rely on driving to
some fancy practitioners usually my
thousand dollar machine to clean out
your colon like something you can do at
your own or on your own at home is going
to be a little bit more sustainable and
consistent and so while those fancy
colonoscopy or not colonoscopy uh
colonic machines
um
work and they they pull a lot of stuff
out of your body and you feel clean as a
whistle afterwards i feel pretty similar
after i do a coffee enema as i do after
one of those and typically it's around
10 to 20 minutes like that's the
recommended amount of time to actually
have the coffee in your in your colon
usually you'll you'll feel some bubbling
sometimes you'll have kind of like an
urge to go but you'll kind of want to
wait if you can for 10 to 20 minutes and
then at that point you just
stand up you get it all out sometimes
it takes a little bit more time just to
make you know on the toilet you know get
yourself a good squatty potty and
you know do you have the toilet really
close do some good breath work and then
yeah and then get it done and uh
and then uh preferably have have an
actual cup of coffee so you can enjoy
real coffee and because i don't know why
but when i do a coffee enema it makes me
want an actual cup of coffee like it
smells amazing it's like yeah i don't
know there's a smell of coffee in the
bathroom makes me want to drink coffee